hey everybody so a lot of people out
there been asking me about my writing
and whether or not there's something of
mine that you can read well today I'm
going to be releasing my first book big
city which I wrote about a year ago on
Gumroad dot-com a digital copy for $3
now I hope that you think that that's
fair I've put a lot of work into this
and I don't think it's so much money
where you know if you don't like the
book you feel that you've wasted it
obviously though I hope that you do like
it you can find the link for the full
text in the doobly-doo today I'm going
to be reading the first part of it for
you firstly because I love to read and
listen to fiction secondly because it'll
give you guys a chance to see what the
book will be like now just a few words
here before I you know get started in
the way of a summary imagine that you're
reading the back flap here in the
bookstore as the title suggests the
story is about a big city and impossibly
big city a vast urban sprawl that goes
on and on in every direction a city you
couldn't possibly see all of in a
lifetime and one in which people get so
easily lost in the confusion of streets
and high-rises and bars and moving
lights it's a science fiction setting
certainly influenced by cyberpunk but
the story is about eight people who are
trying to live and survive in this
chaotic mess of a place and who are all
experiencing this very unique and
strange phenomenon called seeing the
whole thing now there is a secret buried
in this story about what the city is
what seeing the whole thing means about
what they're all doing there but of
course you have to read the whole thing
to find out what did it what that is
okay so go to a dark place getting them
get in the mood
here's the first part of big city called
Mack lud gate
macleod gate returned from the cotan
region also called cote mal a province
in Sector 22 a without a tatter of
currency to his name he had begun his
sojourn to that blistery junction of tri
district gambling not six months before
dreaming of a streak but all he got was
a dark new appreciation for settling
deaths he picked at the scab on his
forehead and thought this is ready to
fall off as the automated female voice
recording spat out the name of his home
district now entering loanin district
tashu province municipal sector 25 a
change here for all Silver Line trams
doors will open on my right and again in
three alternate languages but he was
wrong about the scab it bled here were
the things Mac knew as he stepped from
the tram into loan n1 he could stay at
Shelley's for as long as he liked to the
ice on most of his bets was covered he
had little to worry about in the way of
rancorous businessmen three he was
guaranteed at least one free meal every
day at his uncle Warren's restaurant on
the corner of 15th and Catskill Street
and for there was every chance that mr.
hai Kaun would hire him back to his old
position at L M & P so long as hi con
didn't know that Mac was living with his
daughter he nestled himself into the
cocoon of these near certainties and
used them as a coat against the
unseasonable cold loanin station was
empty and though Mac could not recall
the time when it was otherwise the space
provoked in him the feeling of being
only recently abandoned by a host of
people strange that anyone would gather
here he said to himself as a rush of hot
air moved through the terminal and it
once vivified his suspicions with
paralyzing emphasis hints of phantom
card players eyes receding into their
sockets rhinestone whores
toothless always smiling the flotsam of
degeneracy behind every corner he was
sure of it Mac blinked rapidly to dispel
these apparitions but captured instead
the after images of dusty fluorescence
that spread light through the station
all thin and dry more ghosts they had
followed him here nerves short circuited
Oh God six months of uppers withdrawal
his heart raced away and these silly
tricks of the night so affected Mac's
eggshell spirit that he ran from lone
end station and a boyish frenzy fleeing
a host of illusory terror
Shelley Grave lived on the east side of
Lynette in a triplex behind Jefferson
Park near uncle Warren's restaurant on
15th Ave a building that small was a
rare commodity in loanin and rarer still
she and her daughter Lisa occupied the
whole first floor most of that
district's population was crammed into
the row of towering apartment blocks
that lined the far edge of town but
Shelley had gotten years ago at a low
fixed rent before prices rose
drastically district-wide
fluctuations of that kind were frequent
in all sectors of the city like win
through skyscrapers streets and
unexplainable as a matter of course why
this particular rent stayed fixed is
easy enough to puzzle out if you know
chef Mac knocked on her door hesitantly
in a way a man does when he is merely
trying to prove to himself that he was
there and did that thing really he was
of two minds he needed rest and warmth
some time for his nerves to settle this
was clear from the episode at the tram
station but being here bashfully
knocking like a teenager Mac could not
help but recognize a scene from a story
played over and over it annoyed him to
know what Shelley would say when she
opened the door how he would respond
where the night would go what the next
day would bring and so forth he wanted
desperately to deviate from this plot
but it was hopeless his character always
wanted to deviate in the scene to do
something impetuous or dangerous or just
plain wrong but never did so Shelley
opened the door and the story played on
look a millionaire yeah and it's all
yours he pushed fire what's that I smell
is that fish where did you get fish from
so you expect to come in and what she
had already botched the practice speech
jump in bed with this is in your world
I'm walking around it Mac listen to me I
give my arm for a dose of Zeno God any
but he had already spotted traces on the
coffee table tiny blue specks sprinkled
over the smiles of magazine cover girls
and grocery store coupons he turned over
an issue of celebrity health with the
famous actress Joslin Marquette posing
candidly on the cover and there it was
the feebly hit porcelain jar no doubt a
piece paid by her daughter Lisa in
school bingo
Mack join me will you we can yell at
each other tomorrow I'm deadbeat
he dropped a small blue tablet into his
pipe one thing he had not lost in co'tin
and ground it down with the butt of the
pen one long drag and stupidity crashed
over his mind simplicity yes the end of
all thought he passed the pipe to
Shelley who seemed to have given up her
protests at sight of the drug she was
thinking well finish this tomorrow and
took a drag for herself sweet repose she
nestled herself into the crook of his
arm and together they sank into the red
rayon cushions of the couch nothing
moved the television was tuned to one of
those channels which only plays music
probably because Shelley couldn't afford
a full entertainment package the noise
was faint but Mac caught enough to
discern which channel it was he needed
have heard it though
Shelley only ever played one station
this late at night particularly when she
was dosing City reflections a station
unlike any other its sole purpose was to
catch old frequencies that had been
broadcast and set bouncing into the
city's sound maze of a trillion
buildings
you might hear something on reflections
that had been played a thousand years
ago in a province you would never know
the name of but who could say after all
that bounding and rebounding if what you
were hearing was the music as it was
originally recorded who could say if it
was even music and might just a well has
been have been modulated police sirens
or distress signals maybe the
arithmetical a shion's of an ancient
supercomputer it gave people a sense of
communion anyway it helped them forget
the size of the city or else feel the
magnitude in its full capacity Mac was
proud that his district set the places
he had heard of had invented something
like city reflections he wondered if
other places headed to the music pulsed
over the room cautiously like a vessel
signaling its approach to port in a low
fog and they allowed that strange melody
to fuse its essence with their own both
of them being so dissatisfied at that
moment with the state of being required
by a human mind molecules mingled with
wavelengths were twisted and strewn
mislaid shuffled around transmuted and
exchanged and if afterward only the
music remained so what
the drug was in full effect Mack kept
raising the volume because his ears kept
adjusting and he wanted it to be loud
what was he trying to deafen what's cab
like question still etched at him under
all that noise yes his secret wish for
Shelley not to answer he couldn't have
been in his right mind this was exactly
what he wanted being here with her
weight on him six months of uppers and
the knife's edge stress knife's edge
stress of coated card rooms had set a
system on a dangerous tempo what was the
motive for going to that hole he
couldn't remember or didn't want to but
lonen did that to you it was the kind of
place that magnetized its population
even the slightest relaxation of purpose
would be enough to persuade an errant
traveller that it was time he ought to
go home and it is sometimes said that
wherever a lone end born folk go in
their lives no matter the distance or
duration they always die alone in
Shelley's daughter Lisa awoken by the
music that could not be loud enough
trudged into the living room and found
her mother completely stoned on the
couch with a man of whom she had only
the faintest recollection Lisa knew very
little about drugs but enough to new
know what it looked like when you were
on them Shelley seeing Lisa and her
peach colored pajamas clutching a teddy
bear that had been patched and repatched
dozens of times shot up from the couch
and tried to act to thaw rotative Lisa
why are you up do you want some water or
do you need anything I don't mean to
yell at you the music was loud she said
I couldn't sleep
her eyes were fixed on Mac whose smile
suggested friendliness but she had been
fooled by looks before she chose to
distrust him hey Lisa remember me all
she said was can you turn it down please
and the little girl walked back to her
room feigning all the disappointment of
a mother Mac you asked turn it down and
he did oh this is a disaster why did I
let you ruin everything fuck fuck she
knocked the porcelain jar off the coffee
table and the little blue tablets
spilled and were lost in the shaggy
fibers of the carpet in that very moment
shelly grave swore off Zena friend to
forever so mortified to what she thought
her daughter thought she was but this
was her character's nightly promise and
like the other
was never to be kept please go she
whispered and left him there
instinctively Mac went for the tablets
that had been strewn in the sylvan rug
at asked that proved more difficult than
it should have the drug still had a
stronghold over him now instead of no
thought ideas came swarming into his
head like bees converging again and
again on the same conclusion my reality
is on a loop never had he felt more sure
about something than this
he rewound the day in his head and
played it over he did the same with the
previous six months and before repeated
occurrences of the same night this night
laid out like sardines in a tin and it
all seemed so pathetic
the did he have no control over this sad
circle of events he looked down at the
handful of blue tablets and knew at once
that they were the root cause of his
problems he heard to the kitchen
desperate to maintain control over his
mind before the other part the stone
sucker part could reclaim it he lifted
up the dirty plates in the sink and
dropped the pills into the disposal yes
cut off the supply eliminate up the
opportunity for desire to prey on the
weaker self no indulgence he exhaled and
out came everything bad overcooked fish
wafted from the nearby stovetop mac
wandered again where did Shelley get
fish from he was sure that she didn't
have the money for food that rare
sense-memory set off a tiny projector in
his head a tangled dream of gatherings
at his uncle Warren's restaurant on
Catskill Street birthdays anniversaries
his sister's graduation from the
University of fractus that dreadful
reception after his mother's funeral
when he drank too much and actually
accidentally told mr. Hoyt Khan that he
was fucking his daughter she's a tigress
Bruce real rough but watch out for those
nails a shell Hoyt Khan fired him on the
spot only to rehire him a week later
after many apologies and his promise
that he would break it off with Shelley
forever blaring yellow light the Sun no
passing District Police or was yellow
the municipality detail so fucking hard
to keep track
Co tan was lawless free from that the
wildering rainbow of authority the light
there was always the same color harsh
white raining like a god over octagonal
octagonal car tables
sealing the eyes of your opponents and
turning the heads of emaciated amateurs
like Mack into small chalky skulls
it was also deliberately organized to
throw you off balance
by who hell you knew that going in at
least there you could really lose
yourself at least there you could piss
in the streets
whichever authority it was the light
broke his strands and Mac was suddenly
overcome with a wild hunger he scraped
the burnt leftover fish from the skillet
and slapped it on to a dirty plate in
the cupboard there was a bottle of
bourbon another odd thing to find at
Shelly's he ate slowly like a beast
staving off the urge to devour its prize
in one great bite
fish after all was nothing to sneeze at
and bourbon the life of a king his uncle
loved Behrman always had a glass with
dinner maybe she got the gift from
Warren the fish from Warren as a gift
but and the truth was there on his plate
in his glass mocking him the clever
bitch fish every night if she wanted it
free alcohol all in exchange for
turbulent sex and the occasional dose of
Zeno he rushed at the thought of all
that flaccid skin perspiring greasy and
what did they say about him in bed
afterwards that he was a joke making a
fool of himself could they guess when
he'd return a broken record that boy he
heard it loud and clear in the kitchen
silence no more he scrambled into
Shelley's bedroom found her curled up in
a ball under the covers and in one
vicious motion kicked her from the bed
but the wait was wrong he felt it
immediately to light the small body
crashed into the far wall at first the
little girls scream came as if from far
away and then and then it was right
there
cleaving him into Shelley found her
daughter strewn on the floor like a rag
doll the girl's neck had hit the
protruding windowsill and this sent her
into severe convulsions a bent nerve
probably appendages thrashed against the
faux wood paneling quick sonorous studs
Lesa Lesa she kneeled over her daughter
completely helpless you weren't supposed
to touch a seizing person right she
couldn't remember Mac was in shock his
leg his legs moved and
if by another brain slowly out of the
room his body was taking the necessary
steps to extricate itself from the
repercussions of this horrible accident
an accident that's what it was could he
be blamed for it really images spilled
into his head randomly uncle Warren
drinking bourbon from a perspiring glass
the gruff sniggers of better gambler
something strange distract the scratch
on his mother's coffin how did it get
there oh yes
yes there was a rock hidden in the
shovel of dirt he was supposed to dump
over the casket it drew a line directly
above her knees or her shoulders he
couldn't recall what side the head was
on and Lisa twitching like a broken doll
he found himself in the kitchen again
standing over the sink
Lisa's seizure was only a faint tapping
in the room beyond down in the disposal
he could see the small pile of blue
tablets why had he gotten rid of the
xeno think of the money he was throwing
away stupid to throw away all that money
he would need it now he reached down the
tapping ceased silence and then City
reflection boomed from the living room
television Mack turned around to see who
had turned it on but nobody was there
a contralto voice called out strange
lyrics the creaking of the tented sky
the ticking of eternity I saw and heard
and knew at last the how and why of all
things past and present and forevermore
the universe cleft to the core lay open
to my probing sense an augury that's
what it felt like had he succeeded in D
railing the looping story yes Mac turned
around to the sink and was startled to
see Shelley there standing before him
her face as cold as the night I'm sorry
he said or did she say it her finger was
flush on a light switch but he observed
no light turned on or off when he
flipped it moisture on his cheek Mac
looked down to see his hand being torn
apart by blades so Swift and sharp that
at first he felt no pain and then the
pain came and Mac Ludgate saw the whole
thing